donc
en fait faire un tour du monde c'est un
rêve pour moi que j'ai depuis des années
mais beaucoup d'accidents de la vie dont
mon accident parce que j'étais militaire
pendant 22 ans dont plus de la moitié
dans les forces spéciales j'ai eu un
accident lors d'un saut d'hélicoptères
de nuit et je me suis écrasé à
l'atterrissage j'ai eu quatre fractures
à la colonne et la mâchoire un peu
décalé et du coup c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie de réaliser ce rêve et d'oser
laventure en fait ça fait des années que
je réfléchisse à ce tour du monde et du
coup pour préparer ce tour du monde en
2017 j'ai déjà traversé l'atlantique du
sénégal à la guyane donc de l'afrique à
l'amérique du sud pendant deux mois donc
en fait c'est en quelque sorte c'était
une préparation pour ce tour du monde de
traverser les océans car je savais pas
comment traverser les océans donc
maintenant j'ai un bateau à rames et je
sais traverser les océans donc mon
objectif c'est d'aller à vladivostok et
après vladivostok donc c'est un rêve qui
se construit petit à petit et maintenant
j'ai un bateau à rames et je sais
naviguer sur les océans donc ce voyage a
été préparé comme j'ai dit j'ai traversé
l'océan déjà et après
comment expliquer en fait c'est j'ai
déjà imaginé le vélo je voulais quelque
chose d'atypique je voulais quelque
chose de confortable pour durer dans le
temps donc c'est pour ça que ce vélo se
transforme en lit et que je dors dedans
après donc c'est ce qui me motive moi
c'est parce que j'ai une cause pour ce
voyage c'est d'inspirer les blessés et
de leur dire que tout est possible dans
la vie et que la vie est belle donc en
fait c'est ce voyage c'est un peu comme
si je me mettais dans la peau d'un
blessé et je pars à l'aventuré tous les
jours et par contre le message que je
veux dire c'est de garder le cap vers
son rêve et et que c'est possible donc
en fait je voulais quelque chose de très
difficile car le parcours d'un blessé
est très difficile donc c'est un peu à
titre d'exemple que je veux faire ce
tour du monde et démontrer qu'il faut
beaucoup d'adaptations et que le fait
juste dose l aventure et que le fait de
juste oser l'aventuré beaucoup de gens
se mobilisent pour vous aider et du coup
c'est un beau message du maine
d'humanité et de solidarité également
des difficultés il y en a tous les jours
mais en finale c'est je suis préparée je
voulais que mon qu'ils aient des
difficultés dans mon voyage c'est un peu
un peu bête donc beaucoup de difficultés
mécaniques
électriques même des blessures physiques
mais encore une fois c'est grâce à ça
que l'aventuré plus belle car c'est
grâce à ça que des gens se sont
mobilisés pour m'aider donc ça fait
chaud au coeur et
c'est ce qui fait l aventure que
l'aventuré est belle oui ce sont tous
ces problèmes qui font que l'aventuré
belle finalement car sinon je me ferais
bien chez si je ne ferai que pédaler
donc au final je vais pas dire que c'est
facile mais faire du vélo sur la russie
certes traversé la russie en vélo c'est
très dangereux car il ya beaucoup de
circulation comme partout dans tous les
pays ce qui sera plus difficile
par expérience ça sera quand je serai au
milieu des océans car là je ne peux
compter que sur moi même et la solitude
est quelque chose de vraiment très très
difficile mais à partir du moment que ça
vient d'un rêve même si c'est difficile
et qu'on a un objectif atteint tout
devient un petit peu plus facile même si
c'est difficile car ça vient d'arriver
on laisse qui m'a le plus surpris en
russie c'est l'hospitalité des gens la
gentillesse des gens ils sont toujours
prêts à m'aider et ça c'est vraiment
très touchant et ça fait chaud au coeur
est ce qui m'a surtout surpris un peu
aussi en russie c'est le froid mais je
m'y attendais car je savais que j'allais
avoir un peu froid et sinon c'est aussi
ses grandes étendues ces immenses et
c'est vraiment chouette car sur la route
je change souvent de région de paysages
ou de culture donc c'est un grand pays
fascinant iluv russia rations à elle en
aura chien
oui évidemment mais comme je les dis au
début je voulais un parcours difficile
et du coup il est difficile
mais c'est possible mon raisonnement
était je me disais vu que c'est une
grande route je suis parti de paix cela
des casques à ce jeu jusqu à volgograd
c'est la route dans ma tête je me suis
dit que vu que c'est une route et
internationales qui est beaucoup
emprunté forcément cette route sera
déneigée même s'il ya beaucoup de neige
autour donc dans ma tête c'était
possible même en hiver donc dans ma tête
dans mon idée c'était possible de le
faire en hiver car si les camions
passent pourquoi je ne pourrais pas
passer avec mon vélo et après je suis
entraîné de par mon métier d'avant à
être un peu rustique et du likoud dormir
dehors ne me dérange pas on est de par
mon métier d'avant je suis entraîné à
des choses quand même assez dur et
dormir dehors du coup ne me dérangeait
ne m'a pas trop déranger malgré le froid
et après encore une fois j'ai eu
beaucoup de problèmes sur la route et
mécanique électrique mais ce que je
voulais démontrer justement c'est qu'il
faut s'adapter et je me suis adapté j'ai
adapté mon vélo et mes équipements pour
que tout se passe bien et ça se passe
bien et les gens sur le sur la route au
fur et à mesure que j'avançais me
donnait des conseils et de très bons
conseils car il ici il était très bas
bienveillant avec moi je suis arrivé à
tchita après avoir roulé pendant deux
mois en russie et il fait de plus en
plus froid mais je suis déterminé à y
arriver mais en m'adaptant car mon visa
va bientôt se terminer donc en ce moment
je n'ai ma profession finalement ces
aventuriers là je suis j'ai fait 22 ans
à l'armée comme je les dis et là je pars
pendant trois ans je pense pour faire le
tour du monde et finalement ce voyage je
le partage je fais beaucoup de vidéos
pour inspirer les blessés comme je le
dis et du coup c'est un peu comme quand
mon métier aujourd'hui aventuriers donc
c'est un peu comme mon métier maintenant
car je partage cette aventure en faisant
des vidéos et
des photos pour emmener les gens avec
moi dans mon petit vélo et après dans
mon dans mon petit bateau et après dans
mon petit bateau à rames